this is what state tv in afghanistan
looks like now
taliban fighters parading their arsenal
of weapons and homemade bombs
a chilling propaganda video broadcast to
the nation
in just two and a half weeks afghanistan
is an estate few could have predicted
certainly not the foreign secretary now
playing catch-up in the region
appearing in doha with qatar's foreign
minister dominic raab made it clear what
was top of his agenda
now of course we need to adjust to the
new reality and our immediate priority
is to secure the safe passage of those
remaining british nationals but also the
afghans who worked for the united
kingdom
there are thought to be hundreds of
british nationals and thousands of
afghans who worked for the uk's armed
forces still in afghanistan now in
danger of reprisal
sky news has seen documents for one man
with authorization to travel to the uk
but he didn't make it out
he spoke to us from hiding and tells his
children it's a game
who is looking for us why they are
looking for us because their children
they don't know
and i i usually nowadays i'm playing you
know i i i'm telling them that we are
playing hide and seek game i'm saying
son that we are playing hide-and-seek
again so that's so they are terrified
they are terrified they are scared you
know they can't sleep at night
with no foreign troops now on the ground
in afghanistan safe passage out of the
country is at the discretion of the
taliban we don't recognise governments
and we won't recognize the taliban
government what we are willing to do is
engage because we need to be able to
convey messages there's some early tests
for the new government and we will judge
the taliban and any new administration
on what it does not just its words so
you have no plans to talk directly to
the taliban no i have no
plans
the person charged with that job is this
man intelligence figure sir simon gas is
rarely seen
but he's been in doha for weeks and is
talking to the taliban on behalf of the
uk it's no surprise qatar was first stop
on dominic raab's visit to the region a
critical partner in countries wanting
dialogue with the taliban the british
embassy has moved here to doha from
kabul in the last few days as well but
certainly for now it seems any
engagement between the uk and the
taliban will be done behind closed doors
but already on the ground are qatar and
turkey with technical teams working to
reopen kabul airport one source telling
sky news that could be weeks away
but the new government should be
announced in a matter of days women
taking to the streets in herat province
the taliban already warning it's
unlikely any senior posts will be women
sky news doha